we need a song for that
um sneezed
um bianca it is a
it is a it's a podcast and it is a week
after thanks
giving i don't [ __ ] this is a tough we
just
fig we just went through a tough weekend
in that thursday thanksgiving
friday black friday saturday
confusing sunday confusing because you
think saturday you thought today
i thought yes i had no i knew it was
sunday but i come
also simultaneously didn't know it was
sunday i don't know
mm-hmm this is the only time of year
where i will allow myself to play video
games
literally saturday i played no i played
uh golf just because you can get good
quickly
like oh you mean we golf uh no i
nope just regular with the thing yeah oh
why didn't golf golf
i tennis don't get me wrong okay i'm
taking tennis lessons don't get me wrong
kind of nice with it kind of nice
real ones are in virtual reality i have
a tenant every
come by santa monica 11 a.m tomorrow if
you want to come by
once we hit what do you wear same neil
brennan outfit like nike
no
yeah i go athleisure and uh
and you know i bought a racket
and to match all the
is it a girl or a guy it's a girl
teacher of course why don't you give
like a european dude
because i don't have a sexual fantasy
about it you're a [ __ ] european
tennessee i'm like
my co-host you're joining if you're just
joining us
no this is a wacky podcast that's where
we've got sexual chemistry
so whatever so the week it was a long
week i'll say that
it was a long one in terms of like the
[ __ ] that's on here
dude i thought we were gonna ha like on
mon
tuesday or i think tuesday or wednesday
like well we have to talk about dave
because it was the number one cultural
story in the
country in the country i i'll get to it
later
i thought of something i want to say
about him um but uh
but and now it seems like when when was
dave complaining was that a year ago
um no everything was really like it's so
[ __ ]
slow uh anyhow
so your nose are very funny thank you i
was trying to decipher them
um so the pandemic
i i don't know if i said this on here
but i was talking to somebody
that i don't think i did say it on here
the pandemic
is not interesting it's
groundhog day with very little character
development
there's no bad ending it's just the
ending
well the ending is in sight
i it's just not it's a traffic jam it's
like as interesting as a traffic jam
it's like
so he says the rem everybody hurts video
but there's
no it's like we i was talking to
somebody about
how a bad
writers what bad writers good writers
are going to write about
quarantine and none of it's going to be
interesting
i don't want to watch a scene that's the
other thing i don't i just don't want it
it's not because it's too painful
it's just [ __ ] boring and long
so it's
spare me it's also i mean bad ending
as in every the story doesn't really
change
it's getting worse there's no
development nothing's go
yeah the the plot is going nowhere yeah
and
um it is a bummer it is a bummer and it
still feels a little bit like
oh god i really hope no one i know dies
from it but we're also numb
to the yeah to the anxiety of that
we're really numb to it now but here's
the weird thing
i don't other than the guy from
um stacy's from fountains of wayne
dying uh the band okay they had
hit stacy's mom he died like
early he got it out of the way
um he died early and but i don't know
anyone
anyone else herman cain is kind of the
only
is the main or the ones that'll show the
like
anti-maskers that die well those are the
best
but um those are just great those are a
gift from
from mother aya um but what
i would that but there's no no one
majors that i was talking my mom is 87
she doesn't know anyone who's dead which
i which i find
odd but statistically in her age range
90 of the people that get it live so
i think it's it's mostly i think it's
class based who it's killing yeah people
that can distance people that
have good health care people that
probably don't have comorbidities like
or probably yeah it's people that don't
have comorbidities that that survive
but it is
it's boring it's monotonous
it's a bit like it's not even what they
say war is
long periods of boredom followed by
brief periods of terror
this isn't even that it's like long
periods of boredom followed by brief
periods of
of awkwardness i'm like uh but were you
my math [ __ ] my man uh let me go back uh
[ __ ] uh we're cool right i feel like
we're living it just feels like we're
living in a memory
like um in 50 years
people are gonna have or a hundred years
people can have antiques
like oh this is this is from the 2020.
anyone who tells you it was interesting
if you're listening to this in the
future which you're not
uh you don't know that it may be in
three weeks uh
it was not interesting it was not
riveting
it was it the tension even was pretty
dull
it's now now now weird for a long time
yeah what but i think that was george
floyd i forget largely
george floyd based no at the beginning
everyone was losing my mind
everyone was losing mind about the
chrono virus starting with you
well i didn't like to see my baby travel
um
certainly did not now here's what i
here's the sacrifice i've made just fyi
i
didn't go to an ayahuasca ceremony this
weekend
wow so who are you
padre come back that's how serious i am
about this this is a real this is real
so
what was this what was the setup uh it
was just it was the
it was the second guy it was the more
his name's kai
okay um but they didn't everyone had
kind of gotten tested but i was
looking for some firm assurances
and i could not be provided and i just
thought
i don't want because i spoke to two
people this week
about their experience with covet
somebody we know well
lost their smell and taste for three and
a half months
that i didn't know it had um
yeah and that to me is the scariest
thing because
prior to this the only time i understood
i
know someone who's lost their total
taste
was um through uh like certain cancers
that affect your
tongue and stuff your throat the
radiation
it the my friend's mom lost
she regained 25 back but
which 25 well i will tell you the only
thing she actually enjoys eating is ice
cream
so you're good woman after my honor
let's hey put her in touch with me huh
okay um yeah the i i
uh i yeah it's
i don't want to lose my taste i don't
want to lose my smell
i don't i just know my smell is
everything to me i could i know all that
weird nose vibration surgery for nothing
uh no but it is uh it i just it's a part
of life i don't want to lose my like
feeling in my finger you know what i
mean i just don't i don't it's not
worth ayahuasca it's not worth any of
this [ __ ]
right for i feel like the the thing i
wrote down was
whenever the joke i would always make
about guys in the nba
and and two guys in the nba is
when if you if you're in the nba
all you have to do is just not smoke
weed
seven or eight months a year and they'll
give you 20 million dollars
and a lot of guys still can't do it do
they test for weed
yeah they're they're there's a
apparently in the new cba the collective
bargaining there is
a caveat for weed
there's a carb like cbd oil for sure i
don't
understand why it makes you a worse
place it's not like a enhancement
drug uh there are guys that are saying
it is
it feels targeted no there are guys that
what because black guys like it yeah
i feel like eve has like weed too what i
mean is
whenever there's i feel like they make
these
it's baseball it's a lot of white sports
it is no weed
yeah weed is like it's just they didn't
change the it's kind of a bookkeeping
thing like ah
we're going to take weed off yeah we
have all the everything's printed
i don't want to run the printer again i
just mean
i don't know people who are high and do
better at these i know a lot of
basketball players who
have famously said they play better it's
like a video game
yeah guys that you grew up watching i
just want
don't you just want to sit and not move
i playing basketball in the nba is maybe
the last thing i'd want to do
if i were high i like in terms of just
this is not enjoyable at all
like neil here take this hit of wheat
and then cover blake
be like no i just one or the other in
fact
how about neither i don't want to come
from either um
that's always when i see these guys i go
like i couldn't cover him
like when i when blake walks and i'm
like i couldn't i don't have a chance
um but so i feel like the vaccine
is in sight and all you have to do is
not do dumb [ __ ] like go to a
open open air super spreader event even
though you like the
what it's about you like the way it's
gonna i just i it's a little bit
of um just
foregoing pleasure in the short term i
feel
too i'm i i'm weird i don't want to jinx
the vaccine
so i'm trying not to get excited like oh
this is almost different
no i don't it's not i don't know if it's
almost even when you go to the doctor
you'll be like oh what's this i haven't
heard about it oh god yeah shoot in my
arm fine
no i just feel like every time we get
hopeful
just worst [ __ ] happens i i agree with
you
because i don't i just spoke to a friend
of mine in england and she's like
they're going to start
vaccining people next week and
ours is in a few weeks yeah but i don't
know i mean
of course i hope they do the right thing
and give it to the people that need it
or people that deserve it the most
which is of course rich people it's
going to happen
people are you with me you know what's
going to happen it's going to be
it's going to same thing as tests it's
going to be some fake ones you can get
online oh wait it's going to be a
nightmare
if you the yes the counterfeits
counter passes counterfeit i got
vaccinated badges
yeah that's the big one the immunization
rep papers
huge underground underground underground
i know a guy
you know guy i'll get you some pa i'll
get your papers is this going to be a
thing 100
for because i've read today that they're
not going to get to africa till the
middle of next year
middle of 2022. so really
because they have a really good guy well
the guy the
the guy said
he's like i just i've seen what they do
it's a world health organization yeah
they're not they're who you are who use
world health organization and drug
companies um pretty clear they
no no i thought i thought he meant i
know this vaccine yeah yeah no but
that's the
like they don't they're they don't go so
we got to go to africa
that's not even that's usually the last
that's the last place that
gets [ __ ] it's the poorest you know to
me or one of the poorest no for sure
so so the paperwork
and uh all that [ __ ] but
what is your bianca what's your vaccine
dream
what are you gonna do what's the first
thing you want to do
upon reception i think you know what i
wanted you're trying to [ __ ]
no no um oh yeah you want to go
i wanna i wanna win
okay i want to
travel
but it's stupid stupid covered won't let
me go anywhere
where you want to go i want to go to
thailand
and i want to go to japan and i want to
go
you want to go you want to go to asia
yeah i don't really have anywhere else
i there's no cities i like cities so
i either go to cities or i go now i'm
going to go on ayahuasca journeys
and that's peru costa rica mexico
and that [ __ ] like not the places along
the the amazon so
um i want to go to the caribbean i've
never been there i heard it's boring but
i don't give a [ __ ] i just
really i've never i like him
that's shocking so my
family is from the caribbean side of
panama so
and then we're mixed with a lot of
jamaican which i don't ever really say
but it's all the migrant workers that
moved to panama to build the canal
so that mix what that you don't talk
about it
because it's just people think you're
lying it's like oh and i'm part jamaican
just shut up
i mean it's pick two or three cherokee
for black people
it just becomes like be quiet
um there's these commercials back in the
day and
they would highlight a celebrity was
makeup commercials and it'd be like
jennifer lopez
and then it would say all her
ethnicities and they were so obnoxious
i'm sure like okay and it was probably
just like which do you think you could
throw in
they were negotiating for what countries
everyone has a portuguese
because it sounds hot yeah um no one's
from chat
believe it or not
shine i'm sorry um so yeah
traveling you know what i want to do i
want to exhale on a [ __ ]
[ __ ] waiting to exhale over here
really [ __ ] ha
and have her hit me back with a nice hot
breath
what are you doing dogs though no this
ain't this just at the store
what this is i wanna i wanna i wanna
stranger [ __ ] to exhale on my face
i just want i just i just wanna go back
to just
[ __ ] breathing i just like hey you
remember
a mask free no paranoia
breath situation i don't literally mean
i want to change this i think you
secretly do
hot a hot girl talking really i mean if
you like
position it if you once you put it like
hot girl like
a girl talking really close to your face
being like oh my god um
now did you watch the fight bianca i did
did you pay for it hell no how'd you
watch it
illegal streams baby how where reddit i
don't know about this
one no one or your friend i don't know
snitch no
not my friends tell you off just tell
people i don't know when we tell people
why not because then that [ __ ] up it
[ __ ] up the streams
okay it was already crashing five
thousand times so
i don't know well there's a lot of yeah
i get you but i don't think you could
even explain where it is because
whenever i look at like
if i'm somewhere that doesn't have nba
or whatever and i'll go for planet i'll
tell you off
uh what did you think i loved that
i didn't i don't like these jake and
logan paul dudes they seem obvious at
all
no they have they're so arrogant and
obnoxious they're
the alma wrote they've convinced
themselves their omarosa and it's a tv
show but i don't understand
why any what anyone likes about no i
don't like the minute i
saw their picture five ten years of
whatever the [ __ ] it was i was like
he just looks like a caveman he's not
even he's not
like attractive he just looks like a big
blonde cave person
right so i don't know i've seen some of
their
youtube videos unfortunately it's just i
don't know obnoxious
like dude culture i'm not somebody is
into it
not me um it seems like i look at them
and i go is orange county
that big are there is you can make a
living
only appealing to guys in orange county
yeah and
i guess i mean i live in san diego it's
possible
so so so many [ __ ] pauls
um but i
was like just because it's just cause
he's white
doesn't mean you're automatically rock i
do that part of it that i hadn't even
thought of
because i while he is white i don't want
white credit for it
but whenever in a sun that black dude's
ass
a little like whenever black dudes
assume they can knock a white guy out
you know who i'm rooting for well of
course and you know what
as a more of a black supremacist than a
white supremacist
in that situation i become like well
black dudes i'm sorry i got it i got it
because you're being dicks about this
and not being
anyone can knock anyone out in
everybody's defense
i think those guys are pretty well hated
that everybody just wanted them to
knock the [ __ ] out visually yes but i
did think
i mean you know we're from rival schools
i'm always rooting for the
black against the world right of course
usually i'm with him really
like family family family food black and
white root for black
you'd have to be a special kind of dicky
black for me not to like
for me not to root for you black dicky
black
you know my account dixie um you'd have
to be a special kind of dicky
like yeah and and then you have to be
if now then if black guys are like this
a rap
and part of eminem's appeal is that he
was able to
beat black dudes at their own sport so
to speak or
or tiger woods appeal is if i can clean
it up
real quick uh
where's my race sponge honey um
so it but in this case
i would have been absolutely for nate
robinson
but then the assumption that they
knocked the white dude out
well no one i i felt like that was just
in the back it was less about him being
white and it was more about him being
it's the kind of white he i don't he's
like a he's
feeling like he's like yeah yeah
unlikable
even after he won he's like let me call
mcgregor i was just like
yeah i don't what are you doing it yeah
he's trying to fit that omarosa thing i
do think he even said
you know people hate on me every single
day my life people blah blah so
you know i'm used to the hate i was like
wow
like no they didn't hate you before you
made videos they you just go to
your [ __ ] job at gamestop people are
like
yeah like [ __ ] this guy the way to work
something about him
[ __ ] him no when you go to the japanese
suicide forest
and make fun i just kind of like poor
taste
so i think everybody collectively did
hitler have haters
yeah he did he had a share of haters but
i think they were right to hate him
uh yeah so i think it was just a little
unsatisfying because
it wasn't even that he was so good it
was that nate was so bad
nate had a i said to you or somebody
that even the way he
fell wasn't you never see guys fall like
that in the ring because
because it's such an am the way he was
moving was such an amateur way
he was he wasn't he was from the streets
he was fight street fighter he had and
yes and he had kind of like ants in his
pants
you just wrote me nate does not
understand boxing
yeah like he thought that you like
no one's jumping he jumped into the
knockout
he jumped in he's like once i was
petting my cousin
i was like gonna pet him on the head and
he jumped in and i
this slap it made and he cried
a lot of journalists brought that up
they were like the time bianca
this reminds me of the time bianca
slapped her cousin yeah
but he jumped into it and so the way he
fell
i'm not saying guys never fall forward
but they're
rarely in the air
it was like he was trying to dunk and he
got punched it was like he got punched
in the middle of a dunk
i the fact you literally nate doesn't
understand boxing
yeah is perfect he just didn't
understand he just didn't
it's like he downloaded he got somebody
else's password
he got somebody else's master class
password and just kind of like
watched certain parts of it like
punching and didn't know
um i the memes are so funny and snoop
dogg should
narrat comment on everything i've said
this forever
snoop dogg is a first ballot
show business hall of famer oh my god
he's so [ __ ]
charming charismatic authentic funny and
original he's [ __ ] a
there was a thing where he announced
hockey probably two years ago for like a
minute and he said something i'd never
heard before
i was like it was a minute and just like
said something that was
he used to term that even i was like
nope
i'll look through my books i don't got
it i he
made the whole thing much more enjoyable
yes
uh how was the tyson part i think it was
in
is it called exhibition game or
exhibition match so there was a no
they negotiated a no no you couldn't
knock each other out it's like
okay uh so it was fine and then
at the end was the funniest when they
were uh
talking with the old white guy basically
like did you think he won
he's like what i want you know but you
know i would i win by knocking people
out and people don't think i could go
eight rounds
right which i didn't fully know did he
just yeah but
there was also uh he wasn't allowed to
get knocked out so no one was like you
can't fight for 24 minutes they were
like
if you fight for he get mike tyson is
the greatest 25 second fighter in the
history of
and like of anything so but
once you got him out of that that once
you made it past that
it was he his skills were not
he wasn't he's like a student and all
that [ __ ] but he just didn't have like
he just he's his thing is power so right
you're gonna have the most power at the
front and then you'll have like you'll
throw some out later but
um yeah so he was saying most people
don't think i could go long
and without the knockout yeah because
it's
it wasn't a proper yeah it's not an
actual fight also roy jones
had the body of a handyman he looked
like a handyman
getting changed roy was like oh my god
and roy jones just looks like yeah i'm
here to check on your radiator
like you go and you walk in on your
super
when he's like alone after hours he
doesn't look bad for
roy jones has a super body and by that i
mean he has the body of a super
and i'm proud of him and of course i
wanted to do a thing there was a guy
who worked on chappelle show who there
were a couple guys
who this is when roy jones like an
actual fighter and he's like
somebody was like i think i can like one
of dave's friends smurf
was like i think i could take him and i
was like i want roy jones to kill you
so i wanted to do it it would have been
a sketch where roy jones fights three
guys
at once who think they can take him
but it would have been so [ __ ]
entertaining because they might have be
like if one of them got a nice shot
in it's it would have been
it would have been very entertaining and
i it may be a sport
but like one like amazing guy two
like two female boxers versus
a one male boxer well
three female but or three out of shape
three yeah
yes three out of shape fighters like
that woman in the back
um three out of shape fighter or three
yeah
just three against one somebody in their
prime
i feel like it would be very
illustrative for people like
uh the aaron paul or jake paul what the
[ __ ] his name is
to see like oh people oh he can kill me
yeah they just feel you they're so you
know
it's you don't even understand you don't
even
it's they're so much better than anyone
you've ever spoken uh
so wait i don't really know was rory
jones jr
was he considered he's one of the
greatest
in his ever in his fight in his uh
weight class but he fought too long
yeah because it said his last was 2018
yeah he was fighting too long and then
and but in like the late 90s early 2000s
he was like the best
everybody they're alive found that like
pound for pound all that [ __ ]
uh does do you make a lot of money yeah
do you think he still has him he doesn't
seem
that stupid right um
but uh he's estimated worth five million
so he's pretty stupid
um uh but uh they're all usually wrong
about these
yeah they're they're all wrong so who
knows but he might or might not i think
he lives in ohio so
uh he made 55 million total yeah
in his fight yeah it's great but
it's you know also someone was uh my
friend
online was saying baby girl go she was
posting that
did you know what's his name don julio
not donald don juan
don don king king
did time killed the two people did
everybody know that
uh is that like common knowledge well
there was that movie
bumped to somebody to death yeah
that's right the weird part is he didn't
promote it ahead of time
bianca i used to be in comedy and one
day i will be again
uh oh speaking of used to being comedy
if you live near san diego i'm doing
shows this weekend or friday night in
escondido
and what club is in escondido the grand
cop why good question
grandcomedyclub.com wow but you gotta
get tables of four
that because of covet fine find three
friends you guys
go see me you know what find three
friends you guys can go
put up do a raffle um
okay so you saw that the iranian nuclear
guy
hello got smoked yeah how do you feel
about it i gotta say
as like from a from a jason
bourne james bond angle
i love it i love that oh it's so
theatrical we're in a movie yes i love
it
once you get into uh
the who did it why'd they do it and all
that [ __ ]
is where it gets like then they go it's
from israel i'm like i don't like it
anymore
i know it's like well but the reason no
it can still be
just as the hold on i have a question or
is his
i want you to pronounce his name i'm
going to give you a rating
can i do one name at a time yeah
can i phone a friend no mohsen good job
that's pretty easy okay it's m-o-h-s-e-n
motion there's no not that many ways to
[ __ ] it up now this is the hard part
um okay i just [ __ ] with zeta
[ __ ] accuracy this is my friend
mostly
hello hello iran i'm
calling for a fella by the name of
motion [ __ ] zeta
are you with dickie black are you dicky
dicky black gave me his number
um um yeah yeah i like it and then
i i love that the
the best argument against anybody who's
like
we need control it's always the uh the
uh uh having a gun is everyone's right
people those are all republicans right
everyone should be able to have a gun um
but only certain people can have nuclear
weapons
and it's like how tell me about your
math
how everyone can have a gun in america
but
and but not everyone can have a kind of
bombs
for the same reason to protect
themselves against other
countries it's like yeah it's no it's
just
some dumb um
it's so like wrong and inconsistent yeah
and i don't i'm not
dying for iran to have a nuclear weapon
but you're literally telling
another whole ass country who doesn't
like you a grown-ass country a grown-ass
country uh that
no you can't have those we can't trust
we can't i'm gonna get all my friends
to not hang out with you yeah it's
different
it's different when we have them it's
different so you know what to do and
i'm like vietnam's still suing you for
asian orange
as of this year so asian orange asian
orange
that's all right if that's the name i
can get i can get behind that i like it
people will know what it's about um
the uh yeah i don't i but i do love an
extra judicial killing
i love it as an as a cold open it's a
yeah it's a cold open then boom boom
figure out what's going on
so the mystery is is it israel
it's probably israel right but then why
i
mean
they don't israel and america generally
work hand in glove in terms of
iran right so israel's like no idea who
did that
what and then there's a new york times
quote israel came to the door looking
like roy jones a nuclear weapon
what a scientist i don't even know how
i'd know one
and then israel was also quoted by the
new york times saying uh
the world should be thanking israel
right now because it's
in the world's interest for iran not to
have
who said that so it's a quote from new
york times as somebody in the israeli
defense ministry sure i can barely
remember our
acronym organizations but um
officially israel is like we had nothing
to do with it but there's all these
publications that have a quote
of somebody saying everybody's thanking
us
that's generally a good sign um i'm not
saying we did it but
send checks care of um
so yeah it's i see people are wondering
why and i think
and a lot of other people think it's
because
they don't want biden to
re-join the nuclear deal so they're
trying to
makes it makes it less attractive
for iran and just to show that israel's
not
they're not they're not playing around
they do not want us yeah
again it's a little it's a kind of like
a girl you've dated
it's a little manipulative like okay
well you better not
and then they preemptively do something
to deter you yes
it's like first of all [ __ ] you know
let me become president first
don't do things yeah like yeah let me
can i be president
for one day [ __ ] um
yeah i don't know i don't in some ways
you want to talk about a story that
doesn't change
the middle east is this it's just
[ __ ] endless
it's just [ __ ] endless so i i don't
now that i don't care
it's just i've lived through too many of
these things that i just yeah
i don't know okay and then i'll
sometimes i'll
read into it a little bit and i'll be
like yeah this is a thousand years old
and like it's none of it's right the
west is wrong
there a lot of people in the in in that
region are wrong
but they're [ __ ] by the west to begin
with but then even if the west left then
they're
dicky to each other they're dicky browns
to each other and um
and uh and so i
i don't i just like the killing part
that's all i like right heads i like
getting in a phone and oh hello what i
love the
or a drone or i like that i mean this
here's this is for for cold open a
remote controlled machine gun is insane
is that what it was
wow so there's two stories i like it
even more now i know i was like
so there's two stories right at the
beginning it was
cars full of you know terrorists and
iran blew the guy up
or lit him up right yep then
it officially changed to no it was a
drone
like remote controlled machine gun and
now people don't know what's the real
story because
it would be way more embarrassing if it
was a
car full of terrorists because it's like
you didn't
you didn't because they knew he had a
target on his head for a long time
yeah they even they even uh
like they even figured out where he was
wearing a mask
keep talking keep talking and so
i think people say they might have
changed their story because a remote
controlled
machine gun sounds really cool but
people think it's not here's and it is
really cool
so we don't know why what happened but
you know um
i like i like the road runner yeah
element of it
seriously a lot yeah i like a a robot
came up
and hello and they wait okay
it was an it was from acme it was from
the acme company
um now trump
pardoned flynn this is again
trump is now like uh one of those tv
shows that's just been on
so long and it's a csi
white house and i i
can't believe it's still on and i hear
about plot twists
from it i'm like okay yeah they ran out
they ran out of floods
so yes okay yeah it's not surprising
um i still can't believe
that people like donald trump but
damn what are you gonna do people are
different didn't didn't obama tell
him not to hire mike yes i was like that
guy's a bad
dude yeah yeah because they knew he was
working with russia and turkey and all
these other [ __ ] countries
but it's that it's their own sphere it's
their own it's
it's it's in some ways it's like the
the it's like some narnia [ __ ] where
it's a it's a it's all fan fiction
yeah the stuff that actually counts the
stuff that they actually do
doesn't count the only thing that
matters is fan fiction is
fan fiction written by trump about
reality
so that that becomes like lock her up
for what because she's done horrible
things
what you know and then that becomes the
so they're living in this alternative
reality um
and uh it's sad
it's just sad it's just a i don't i also
don't understand why you can pardon
people i don't understand
why that's are people going to stop
running for president if you take that
away
i like the parking i don't even want to
be pr i was going to be until you took
the pardons away
dude pardons are cool they're a real now
talk about a plot twist
not this one but i like the idea none of
them are like
very obama
oh can you name any of obama's pardons
um
i think a lot of uh non-violent drug
offenders he pardoned a lot of them
i don't i think he pardoned i feel like
i read
that and i he pardoned the didn't he
pardon the most
at least i believe are you sure yeah
do pardons by president so obama had a
lot no
trump no had 28 pardons well this is
old but uh oh no
no it's okay so it's from the 24th obama
had
212 pardons but 1700 complications
commutations is what he did with the
dr non i think a lot of the drugs so
total clemency
you're right other than fdr fdr had a
loose was loose with the clemency
and uh woodrow wilson this guy would
[ __ ] pardon anybody
um i like that trump's trying to
pre-pardon himself
yeah he's trying to give himself a
license to crime
um like no i'm it's okay i'm pardoned
like he'll do [ __ ] just knock you down
and be like i'm pardon my fault dog
you know i didn't hear i got pardoned
it's so cra
it's so crazy but if anyone can get away
with it
it's big it's the ratings machine donald
trump and by
speaking of the ratings machine yes
there was a story this week about
how much the washington post and the new
york times
circulation has gone up since 2016. oh
yeah
yeah of course both of them tripled they
should all
every news media outlet should send him
a [ __ ] basket
yeah at least at least i mean because
from for their bottom line
he is so interesting i mean maybe
not positive but that's bad for the
country because good p
will triple your circulation so that's
right
so that's great so now i'm with them now
i like them because i love the new york
times and i'm a real [ __ ]
you guys know i used to do a tv show
with dave chappelle i don't like to talk
about it and
he doesn't either actually yes sure he
does sure we both do
it was great uh dave was
upset this week because
comedy central sold viacom
a publicly traded company sold one of
their assets
to another publicly traded company their
assets being spell show
um wait who sold it to who sorry buy
companies
owns company central they sold it to
netflix and hbo
um so and dave
didn't like it because
he doesn't get money from it
and i i
the thing that i want to talk about is
people going people writing like i hope
you get money too
my what i would suggest is i think you
hope i get money
up to a point i think people
want me to get money they want me to get
like
some money but i said yeah i got five
million dollars you
your like for me would [ __ ] plummet
if you thought i had money like that
it's a weird thing where you want to
make
a good amount of money but not so much
that people don't like you
and it's a very easy trap to fall into
do
have you experienced this when people
yeah
rich mother people just call me [ __ ]
that's like
i did the work and also you you bought
the dvd dummy
i didn't do the work thinking i was
going to get rich from it or
if i did get rich yeah um who says
he wasn't um so
i don't you can't acknowledge you just
can't money's [ __ ] crazy why does
that bother you though
because they act like because it becomes
a they act like it's a civil rights
issue like i hope
they did the right thing by you and you
got money it's like no you don't
you don't you know someone trying to say
i hope you get money you
find the because i know what would
happen if i told them how much money
it was they'd probably just be like oh
then they wouldn't they trust me what
i'm saying isn't crazy
no i believe you i'm just trying to
understand mad
it's the difference between being
the thing i've said to blake i don't
know if i said on the podcast but
having a rookie contract is more fun
than having your five-year 40 million
dollars a year contract
because everybody knows everybody's yeah
everybody knows
what you what you're making and
your rookie that's like hey i remember
when you were then then you got this
rookie deal and
even though it's 5 million a year it's
still like yeah you're gonna get your
mama huh
that money goes quick once you get into
like crazy contract money
you're you're just an [ __ ]
just automatically you're a little bit
of an [ __ ] um
does it bother you or do you care uh it
doesn't i
i accept it i it's just funny to me when
people go i hope you got money and i go
to a point because you'd after if i if
it gets over a certain amount if it's
like
a hundred grand you'd be cool if it's
1.3 million no i think people will be
cool with 1.3
i feel like 5 million 5 million for it
gets crazy
by the way everyone's got a different
number five million really yeah
everyone's got a different number
everyone it's your
right exactly everyone's got a number
that's like
over that you don't deserve it but
meanwhile
what do i just what do i what do you
think i deserve based on knowing what
you know about the show which is
virtually not like yeah you know what i
mean i don't have a number i think you
should get as much money
right but i'm not mad at people i just
think it's funny when they say that
because it's not
it's it's not you want dave to get money
as a
grieved famous person that you love
once you get into me you're like hmm
it's not so passionate i'm white
you know what i mean like there's just
things that people hit you up about the
situation
[ __ ] endlessly oh my god [ __ ]
endlessly
um it's endless that's the thing is and
it
do you love the noises i'm making with
my cup i'm speaking with glass
it was definitely stressful monday and
tuesday because it's just like
did i help energy
you didn't say anything i didn't do that
because i just thought no i know that's
what do you mean did you help did aya
help no i said aya
yes i did yeah yes
yes did help because uh
i i shuts down the default mode network
meaning i couldn't really ruminate up
about it
and also one of my roommates i love the
non-rumination effect
it's like uh it's just not you just
think about it
you think about it you pour it over your
you think three thoughts
yeah and then you just go ah yeah
whatever and then you
and then you move on and five hours
later you're like i haven't thought
about that in a while
every time i think about something i
haven't thought about i'm like yes yeah
you still you know there's an article
dude
in um the popular mechanics about
ayahuasca this this week oh no
it [ __ ] made you not operate
machinery
it was just saying there was a study
that came out like two weeks ago about
ayahuasca
that i don't know if we talked about
where you grow brain cells
i don't recommend garbage i've said that
a million times no i know i just i'm
just
no i no the articles are insane it's a
superfood
yes it's like beyond a super it's beyond
a super food yeah
it's like a tail you're not gonna
believe it's better than avocados
better than kale better than chemicals
yes uh
so it did you regrow brain cells
it's yes just if you do ayahuasca brain
study and it'll be from november 20th i
think and
uh god forbid we'll do it
so you tell
actually happening you know when you get
a car and you notice your car everywhere
yeah i i'm starting to do the ayahuasca
and i can't tell if more shit's coming
out about it
it's been a big month for highways
publicly okay because i was like
stimulating everywhere berkeley
foundation or beckley foundation
stimulates the birth of new brain cells
um it's a thing that could potentially
reverse alzheimer's
oh my god so do you don't take my word
for it
how's contact that's
you begacked full people listening right
now this
the gag fool's talking some [ __ ] um
so the so yes i helped with the dave
thing
and i don't have much to say about it
other than
uh i find it stressful
and and i
wish he would sue them or something i
don't [ __ ] know um
because it just seems to do it in public
seems like just
not it's not effect it's like if you if
it's illegal guys [ __ ] sue him
but i mean court of public public
opinion sure
but yes and then what but what's the and
then what did he
so he wins what
what's kind of like you know like this
the swifties or the beehive
people are just like of course
yeah that is that does i mean no matter
who you are on earth whether you're
chinese government or netflix or
just a person doing podcasts no one
wants heat
who's gonna feel bad about it it's a
publicly traded company the chairman
some weird [ __ ] people care about
their image come
on not at that level they don't buddy
they don't want to get caught with a
prostitute but like
okay hey your corporation ripped me off
yeah we're a [ __ ] corporation
good for us that's what we do right
lowbar yeah
um i like that yeah whatever um
then there's the gram a lot of people
complain about the grammys what
the weeknd complained the weekend got
upset that he didn't get nominated
um and uh you're looking at me like
you've never heard of the weekend
or the grammys i have i'm just
oh you're late uh he got upset
and everyone's like i you know what's
funny when people get
upset they start talking like they're
from the middle ages let me see
where it's like the grammys remain
corrupt
you owe me my fans in the industry
transparency
like why are we all talking like we're
from the middle ages
um i don't here's my thing with a guy
like the weeknd who
is a is a is a decent guy
uh a nice dude in my experience
um why do you ca people commented by the
people complain about the grammys every
year since
that i remember 1989. so that's 31 years
because or maybe it wasn't 18 in 89
jethro tull beat metallica
because it's a beauty pageant right
judged by old people with bad taste
so i was speaking to
another music industry person who said
there's an easy way around this which is
don't submit
you just don't submit for yourself
programming and then you
oh you have all of these are submitted
oh they're all submitted
so what they're mad about is that they
all entered a beauty pageant
and then didn't win didn't get nominated
for for a pretty prize it's tellers and
tears
yes and they are mad it's just silly
because they're
it's like you're still doing the super
bowl who i don't know who has grammys
do you know what i mean i don't know as
a fan i don't go like the
there's a one of the grammy songs is on
right now grammy winners
would you keep it down everybody grammy
winners on the radio [ __ ] no
um and once i heard that you don't
submit i was like oh
this is silly it's all silly um or start
your own thing
i feel like if enough i mean the grammys
have
historically ignored a lot of uh
all hip black they never get rid of
anything no it's never good never it's
just
loren hill one i think kendrick one like
that's but then i talked to another
music industry person who said
it can open doors up if you win a grammy
of course
but i don't understand how
somebody in music with good taste would
all of a sudden
want to work at kendrick lamar because
he won a grammy you know why
because it's just a self-congratulatory
prize
for within an industry and everyone in
the industry is like oh
wait on you you have a little bell
you've got i but i find
if i'm if i have if i'm an
artist with any integrity right i
already knew kendrick lamar was great so
now that i now that he wins a grammy
i wouldn't want to do a song with him
more
and i'd actually want to do something
less because it would cost more but you
always tell me yeah
you will not believe everybody has a
gigantic ego
you always say that incredible they're
all have incredible
in very easily shatterable egos so the
less
the less disparity between you a person
with a big ego
and someone who want a grammy
i mean that is you know it kind of rubs
off on you it's like i worked with a
grammy award winner
we all buy into it but i think the
bigger problem is he won
he got a grammy i'm dope too
[ __ ] and i
you so you're saying i'm not as good as
him but he has to be nominated before
the weekend has won he got nominated for
some weird
duet song this year no but
he's won a grammy uh he did
not the ones he wanted he won r b
performance urban contemporary
album that sounds so an urban
contemporary album
so yeah but his point i think his bigger
issue
is that album of the year they only see
him as a black artist and not they see
him as
urban and not uh not he makes pop songs
he makes the [ __ ] disco he should get
disco
right disco prizes but that's when it's
like okay but you're going
up like there there's so much
that's why when we talk about people get
up
genre right when they get snippy can i
go back real quick
now people still love disco by the way
there's a bg's documentary coming out on
hbo
i love [ __ ] getting ready to cancel
everything
when i don't i saw a commercial for it
so they usually premiere on mondays
could be today oh my god is it tonight
uh how do you met a burger how do you
even broken heart
full movie this came out already
watch the trailer available december
12th at 5 00 pm pacific i'll see you
okay um so
so uh wait so yeah so but the weekend
again it's it's trouble it's really both
of these are trouble in the winner's
circle
that's playing drama yeah
i mean it sounds like the vg's it really
does
it
uh yes now this is for the next so this
is what these white people don't i'm we
what i realize over the weekend we have
so many songs that we never use i know
we gotta
um now i don't know if you saw this but
this defy this is on twitter on saturday
there was a
uh a black woman wrote an
article for a magazine that
is uh and it was about outcast
and it was called the art of speculating
right
so you know how people can't do anything
for themselves anymore so
they need audi not only do they need
audio books they need
audio articles seriously you read it
that's basically what everyone's doing
like i don't get you read it to me
uh so i think i if you read what i sent
you i think they pulled the audio down
yes they pulled the audio down but i
made sure that will
ripped it i didn't get the phone no of
course
you couldn't get the full clip but so
that's the setup
listen so then they hired a white guy to
do
read the article for you okay and it's
pretty unbelievable okay
fireside magazine presents the art of
speculating
stop it what why just
did you happen do that where is that
accent
it's [ __ ] jar jar bin yes it is jar
jar banks
he was doing but even george rings was a
black dude yeah he was well it was
jamaican
um
speculate play that again please
fireside magazine presents
the art of speculating
why did he say it like that oh that's
what this
voice should be called from now on doing
this voice is
he's doing that especially
there was a guy he was doing the art of
speculating it's when a white guy does a
black
patois yeah the art okay hit it
the art of speculating by regina
n bradley edited by maurice broadus
narrated by kevin rainier published in
the autumn 2020 issue of fireside
twitter i'm a southern black woman who
stands in the long shadow of the civil
rights movement
southern hip-hop helped me navigate the
contemporary black south
that's the whole that's all we were able
to literally like steal magnolias with
yes
just like offensive steel magnus like
yes i'm a southern black woman he's
saying the
loud [ __ ] of dukakis in in
i it sounds like
why whatever do you mean it sounds very
like the warner brothers cartoons would
have been like hey what are you doing
what i'm a southern black woman
who stands
i can't believe i can't remember not
yosemite same
none of it stumped us [ __ ] um i'll
remember
okay um but um
cartoon hey wow that's the worst thing
will well that will's so bad at the
internet because he
searches the worst thing it's just
warner fox
yes cartoon head cartoon like it was a
man
no well do i need you to do better
sometimes you get
whatever hitler had a lot of haters um
the art of the odd internet description
the art of googling by will hagel
i'm will hagel and i'm from i'm i'm from
from indiana or somewhere like that
i got
um why did you just unbelievable
get into the mind of a wife all right so
i had this argument with a friend of
mine who
it was asian and she was saying asian
yeah
whatever how'd they get involved she
said asian
she's asian and asian she was uh and she
was
she was saying that that
is malicious almost like white people
doing it intentionally and i was like i
don't think i think it's just
dumb i don't think he seemed like really
pumped and like he worked on that
i yes i don't think he just threw that
i think he was like oh i swear to god he
worked on that no i
he's took a class all that he's done
he's trained um but
letting him do it and then hearing it
and saying
let's i think we go to press with this
hit
send i love it cut and print
yes uh that's where you get into
i don't think it's malice but it's
deep stupidity bad it's like a major
oversight why did you think to hire
white guy also when you go back to the
um well you go back to the
uh article it's just i'm like let's just
say without a direction
why would you my guess is that he reads
six of these at a time
he just goes in for a session and does a
bunch of articles
right and this is one of them and i'm
sure they have
black men read for white women and i'm
sure they do racial mix-ups
yeah really often you i mean i've
listened to a book on tape before and
you one person's doing all that
you listen to the
my name is ahab and i'm a captain c
and i'm out in the ocean looking for
whales i
am um i'm just like
i think it's just stupid and not it's
there's a
for there's an old man phrase well we
will you um
hit it will will hit it correctly please
great very good um there's an old man
which is uh
malice which could easily will you
scroll down the article for a second
do not describe it's uh hanlon's razor
never attribute to malice that which is
adequately explained by stupidity
hanlon's razor hand little raisin
um so also when he i just i'm sad we
didn't get
that seven seven playlists
i'm sad we didn't get to the iranian
name you made me do
my you made me do the artist speculating
i really did
but you pass yeah far crazy
yeah um i just don't
yeah i just it's they so they put out so
anyways they ended up putting out a
statement
saying you know about our audiobook
look it was stupid of us yeah so the
lady retweets the lady who wrote it
retweeted it and was outraged they took
down the audio obviously
and you're saying that the guy took down
his twitter he took down his whole
i do feel like this he wrote his last
thing was i
deserve covet no are you joking yeah oh
yes you're doing a comedy podcast i
deserve coke i know i'm just crazy
there should be a wheel where there was
an
old bit on conan i believe
and it was where they had they had new
york cab drivers
do a seinfeld impression
and it's just like river dirt like
indian like
a poo indian guys like with straight up
that's how they talk
doing like have you seen and it's
so [ __ ] funny and racist it was from
the 90s but now it's so racist
that you but it's fun to hear people
with stereotypical voices
talk like somebody else with a
stereotypical one
yeah it is funny it just once you put it
it's funny amongst friends
or it's funny just don't publish it
save it for the group text everybody
that's not it's like yeah
that's it that's it save it for the save
for the group tag now
currently seinfeld did found the other
night and they did another they did a
contest where people did jerry's bits
they did an impression of seinfeld and
an indian woman did it and it reminded
me of the old
[ __ ] but it was funny it was funny and
uh a little racist
but who's who gets who's who gets hurt i
mean i know who gets hurt everybody
um did you see the french riots
i didn't see the riots but i know that
that was a music producer we got beat up
no
well there's a whole another 100 000
people
uh but it was because oh it's because of
the law there's a law
that says they can't look for it in your
local listings i'm sure they'll try it
here
where you're not allowed to film cops
sometimes no all times now it's illegal
oh it's illegal to film cops
film cops yeah but um i mean when if
that happens in france i'm like
how did that happen but people are upset
because
old old macaroon he
yeah he ran uh like very liberal
and now he wants to be i think like a
law and order president
so it's just it's that's why the rub is
so bad yeah
and also it's in a free society
you got to be able to film cops yeah no
sorry
i don't know what to tell you like
everyone else is being filmed
somehow cops is yes not but special i
mean they can't have nuclear weapons
um there's that is upsetting there i did
read an article about
um france you know like 200
000 not 200 200 and i believe 16 people
have been killed by
uh muslim terrorists there and like
pretty recently
so they have yeah they have like a they
you know like the guy ran people over
someone got a teacher got stabbed but
this is
specifically specifically like muslim
terrorism like
terrorism in france yes will god forbid
hey [ __ ] you man um muslim terrorism
uh lesmond reported in 2016 that islamic
terrorism had killed 236
people uh in france the preceding 18
months that's the bataclan that's
other [ __ ] but like they have a
different
they they they're they do the thing
where like they have those [ __ ] burka
laws
they have id laws that are really
impressive
they're in a tough spot because they're
trying to
they're they don't know what to do no
and i've gotten in some arguments with
friends that are french and they're
friends
maybe we're all in the same place and
talking about it and
a lot of french people who are
considered liberal
drink the kool-aid of anti-veiling
anti-you know islamic expression like
expressing the religious freedom
and the reasoning is so strange i mean
one argument i heard
was that well if you're coming into our
country
and you want to assimilate and have a
good life here
we don't we don't do that with our we
don't wear those things they do
i've heard the defenses they don't like
they don't allow crosses they don't
allow anything
but they're talking about they were they
were they were debating not allowing
the notre dame cathedral for instance
not allowed
defending that law the cross law they
were trying to cross law
um not allowing it at
uh not allowing it at um
at all like wearing it outside and the
idea is that oh well if you want to
assimilate to our
culture it's going to be harder for you
when you look so different yeah
it's like yeah i don't you don't know
france i i think that there's the truth
this is a big is this is almost
the big question is does
islam are islam
and western values compatible that's it
because like and they would always hold
up turkey and it's like getting
pretty muslim over there but again like
pretty theocratic
between you and me but if you take
extreme
western cultures like ex it's just
extreme religion
and they look the same you have someone
with their gun
and a american flag being like don't try
it on me and
they're not doing it in the name of a
religion though
unless you consider capitalism or
southernism
confederacy or religion but they all are
very close like christianity because
i don't know the answer okay let's go do
you believe that
islam that there can be a capitalist
society
with uh a capitalist uh democratic
society
with um a
majority muslim population
but there are there's turkey which i
that's what i'm saying it's getting way
less like uh lots like a lot in the
former yugoslavia a lot of them were
muslim um
in um philippines uh bali observable
right
they all have strong they all have like
these are not
exactly democratic countries
okay so you're saying like a fully what
i'm saying is
it starts turkey being the best example
because turkey was like the
city on the hill right and then erdogan
got in
and it's getting like more like huh
you're turning it into a mosque that's
too bad
um so i have
knowing my limited knowledge on islam
i'm sure i'll
will get emails um it is
uh my understanding of islam is that
it's kind of not compatible
like the good thing what are you talking
about you're talking about an economic
system
and then what are you saying democracy
that's not that
that uh you're electing people based on
you have laws that aren't based in
muslim fundamentalism right but there's
it's really hard to find just square one
an example of
good healthy democracy uh absolutely so
that's already i mean
mexico is not islamic it's very hard to
find democracy there
yeah very hard to find democracy
everywhere if you want to say capitalism
i mean if you go to europe a lot of
those aren't like
it kind of i think it pigeonholes us to
compare ourselves to okay let's
for the sake of argument yeah let's say
that america's a healthy democracy
okay right let's say that england
healthy democracy let's say francis
right
they want to they they claim
that they're they're
i guess it's let's not even talk about
let's talk about
civilization right or or uh
french society as it's been known since
since the [ __ ] revolution yeah right
are they right to worry that
preponderance of muslims will make
french society less the way it's been
and if and or is it one of those things
of like well [ __ ] it that's what happens
when you have
if you're then end immigration like you
know what i mean like
it will be less the way it's been it
will be more it was
not especially religious but i'm
assuming it was christian
right it will be muslim it'll be like
the
the are they if you're a white french
person
what would you think do you think i mean
it's weird when
you have french people that are so um
against change when they have such a
terrible colonizing past where they
literally go to other countries
and completely change the way things are
change the dominant
language even yeah change their by the
way
algeria didn't like it lg didn't like it
right
so what nobody likes right so that's
what i'm saying yeah you
kind of do it i'm not talking about like
what goes around come
i'm not talking about any principle
other than
um are they gonna like change from their
culture that they knew no
no one likes that that's not comfortable
right and so what should they do
do you know what i mean right but i
think there's
you know it's a part of life saying like
you know back when i was
this or like ah it used to be like this
i mean what can you do about that what
can you do
about the fact that when you lived in
new york it might have been cheaper or
it might not have been like this like
that right so that's what you're what
you're saying
it's like yeah that's just the sands of
time stands in time but
also the effects of having a really
robust
uh like your hands in lots of countries
in colonization history
so then you go you invade all these
countries all these countries literally
all these african countries speak
french they learn from yes they do it
bianca
and when they want to come to your
country now it's a [ __ ] problem okay
again i don't that's i don't that i
that part of the argument is like well
they hated it so now it's like she was
in the other foot
so of course france is going to hate it
but but francis but
france is in power in all these
situations even when
they oh yeah they didn't listen at all
they didn't care that that
algeria for instance didn't but they
still maintain power
they still maintain power in all these
situations it's not like
algeria has more power over france like
france is
gonna maintain no but what what french
white people it
from my understanding is they're afraid
that
some sort of islam depending on whether
it's
like the different sects whatever
um salaf any i can't remember what they
called salafi is that one did i make
that
uh shiite not shia there's the one
that's from saudi arabia that's whatever
oh yeah
um so so are they're worried about
in 50 years france is gonna look like
right now for instance france looks like
more like me and will
and they're afraid the people that look
like me and will are afraid it's gonna
look like
you and what uh
shia and then there's a different one
um well hobbyism there you go um so
what should they do i get see because
like in america
it's were i'm completely like
the joke i did about like [ __ ] her way
out of racism like america is
gonna look like you regardless because
that's like our
thing you know what i mean yeah that's
right we have no choice
yes it's happening but why you you're
kind of
looking at the situation in france with
a little different lens
i'm looking at this then the situation
in america
absolutely because scared white people
[ __ ] changing and not looking like
howard but i don't here i don't
care cause it's just
a demographic change that we've that's
we've welcomed and it's been out
inevitable
how is it not welcome there because
well i don't know i don't know how
they're not like considered the melting
pot i don't think like
their thing isn't immigration that again
i'm [ __ ]
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about but my understanding of it
it is just their old colonies did at
some point have
like agreements where they can go back
and
yeah um a lot of them did that's why
they're there
yeah so it's even more
like you know that was only a few
decades ago maybe some of them still
have it
whereas black people were in like so
what i'm saying is i'm
french magga yeah but why it doesn't
make it doesn't make sense
compared to everything french culture it
is bread and cheese and the [ __ ]
eiffel tower and
like that's they got you want to talk
about a culture over here it's just like
[ __ ]
hey you're being hypocrite i'm being
absolutely hypocritical
i'm like no i don't know why i'm french
magga but i
am i'm a i'm a [ __ ] wait am i oh my
god you [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] is funnier um yeah i'm a [ __ ]
and
and i don't because i'm more protective
of french culture
i look i'm also
muslims are not overrunning america you
know what i mean like there's not a big
there's no muslim like there's no
charlie hebdo there's no
overrunning france they're overrunning
parts of cities look up
french muslim problem no
don't look that up a population of gotta
be problem kidding
uh so that was about somebody got
somebody got stabbed last week for
teaching
about what happened with charlie hebdo
teaching oh no i understand there's
islam in france
that should be okay uh the majority of
muslims in france
uh 5.8 of the population very small
yeah so that that's what i mean but they
have all the explosives
but we are making it yeah they have a
hundred percent of the explosives
you know what and the machine guns i
need you to to think about
your [ __ ] position because in the end
what the french have done
in their colonization and their version
of white supremacy
is uh longer reigning more powerful and
more disgusting than
than america it's just it's just went on
a lot you know what i mean a lot more it
was just a lot more encompassing
so and the each each country has their
own
terrible story of i'm seeing a sentence
that might
help my argument france's status as
an officially secular nation um
and jihadists refer to france's the
flagship of disbelief so they're
i guess it's like they're continuously
testing
public displays of of islam pd
pdi and the french don't like it and to
me it's an
eyesore it's basically that and it's
like okay the more you try to erase us
well then the more louder we didn't you
see didn't you see uh
[ __ ] what is it the
the gat damn foxhorn legend
no it was the movie the famous french
movie
les
no it's [ __ ] great it's training day
french training day great
it's so [ __ ] yeah i heard watch
french training day
let me then we'll let's circle back
let's see how much effect okay i'm gonna
look
i'm gonna i'm gonna research this a
little bit and by that i mean
10 minutes of light you're going to find
a document
by the way i'm reading a book i'm
listening to a book on tape
read it to me uh the art
uh called the
end of expertise i believe
okay and it is so [ __ ] good
is it about all the armchair experts the
death of expertise yes
and it's just amazing it's all the same
we were saying which is like it's just
egos people don't want to admit
that because i told somebody i was
reading they're like oh about all
how the elites are i'm like they are
elite
they're elite i'm gonna like
it's like you know in japan where it's i
think
it's maybe not the sas
quote right now but historically people
would specialize in one thing
so it's like this guy makes this sort
yeah and his grandfather made this sword
and his father's father made this one
sword and so you have all these kind of
experts but
it's really revered in japan and i feel
like in america
someone would be like i can i'm going to
go on youtube and figure out how to make
this
oh that's like it's also but he's so
isn't his blood like we have to give
credit where credit
some people dedicate their lives to
plant dna
yeah and they like or are viruses
for instance like anthony fauci whose
roommate was aids
um but he's somehow
it's just resentment and the lack of
belief
that's what i was getting at with the
roy jones thing earlier it's like that's
what i loved about
the malice of the palace when all the
fans stormed out
and you see how much bigger jermaine
o'neill is than you thought he was from
a hundred feet away you can literally
see people the guys that charge the
court
at the nba game realize like holy [ __ ]
yeah you're so much bigger than me and
but they don't know because they live in
a world like
i could [ __ ] do that like no you
couldn't
yeah you could there's not a world in
which you could do
most of the [ __ ] you said [ __ ] do it
no you couldn't
um yeah it's it's so i i was talking to
somebody
a friend of mine who is an anti-vaxxer
which is very sad for me
and um she just kept quoting it's like
heavy metals
like there's heavy there's so many
there's
toxins in the heavy metals and i'm like
you know i don't want to [ __ ] on her but
it there's so much misinformation out
there that it's really easy to
be persuaded if you don't if you don't
factor
the facts thinking you're smart and it's
proof that you're dumb you think that
you got
the better fat it's like the f where are
you going to accept facts from
wherever i like them
that's it right but that's not a good
that's not how edu that's not how
information works i know but what do we
what are we to do
oh well we need one one one hose
and it's called the new york times
there was a female kicker bianca
they let a lady kick a football are you
angry and
and uh vanderbilt she
she kicked off and uh what i gotta say
is
did you do good no did you do bad
and no one's gonna say it was a bad kick
but it was a bad kick
really it was i don't know if she was
going if she was obviously going for an
onsides kick but
but it's just not a good it was just not
jitters come on it's gonna be no i get
it she's
it's gonna be jittery but it's like
jackie robinson
didn't throw up on himself the first
time at best
talk about pressure yeah talk about life
you gotta
when it's preparation and and uh
uh opportunity meet and then whatever
i'm happy for her and and i hope uh is
she hot
i don't know i thought that that matters
i just can't see her face
um well good for her yeah she uh
there you go hopefully but now that i
got it yeah it's whatever whatever
so um doc watch
ayahuasca on the come up
real sports lead story
i feel like we did this we didn't i sent
you the clip
no no neil you're not hearing me padre
i feel like we oh we we made it happen
i feel a lot more people are talking
because i'll talk about people like you
know the other day someone was
mentioning ayahuasca after i listened to
your pocket i'm like
i i think it's a case of of you know
it's all happening like the same time
it's vocabulary when you hear when you
read a new word
like [ __ ] did you know preponderance
um means a lot of something uh
but it was a hockey player who was like
a goon
and those guys all have cte
yeah all of them have concu black like
they have
dicky black brains their brains truly
the like the meat turns black and this
guy's name is daniel carcillo
and uh so the
there's an ayahuasca um
anyhow but the guy had all that all the
[ __ ] that happens
oh slurred speech mood swings
all of it does it help dementia if it's
already going
what do you mean does it reverse it
yeah or does it in this case
he had one does ayahuasca once
and all of it gone shut the [ __ ]
up all of it gone to the point where his
wife
it's a probably an 11 minute story look
for it on real sports this month but
his wife completely confirms it
com like completely confirms everything
about it
and uh and it's
i sent it to somebody they were like
crying i we can't show the clip but
but it's all and he also does a litany
of things that
symptoms that are gone that even the
litany is mentally impressive were you
like oh that's
what he just said just now is proof that
his brain is better um
so that was [ __ ] amazing so watch
that i mean literally
my ocd is i know i told somebody that
and they were like
are you [ __ ] kidding me somebody was
really bad ocd
i don't wanna the thing is i don't to
promise no i'm not promising anything no
i can only just say
yeah exactly i even now i'm like
i really can just
completely walk away from an intrusive
thought
i don't have to live it out i don't have
it doesn't have to go
somewhere yeah it's just it's not yeah
in my
it's just not in my it's not part of you
who you are it is
i sent it to uh i sent one of our clips
to
a buddy of mine who who's like famously
fights depression and he was like
oh [ __ ] it turns off the default mode
network so i can stop telling myself i'm
a piece of [ __ ] every minute
yeah like yeah literally you're great
yeah kind of
a lot yes for me at least yes um
this guy is
great and you know what's weird the
other day i
did stress about something legitimately
stressful
not you know something i conjured up my
brain
and it was a little bit stressful for a
second because it was something that was
stressful
yeah we're not beyond stress no it's
things
approach don't you dare write us
anything questioning what we've said
here
no more hate mail um and
it was so healthy it just processed so
healthy
and then i don't know it never got
stressful internally it was just
i cognitively understood it was a
stressful situation and obviously
stressful thoughts come with that but
they
didn't go anywhere there was no worse
cases
it doesn't it was i thought recently
that
i mean it's so obvious but a mood
is the hangover from a
feeling or it's the
the aftershocks of feeling and you're
just like
my moods have been really clean
like really not [ __ ] up and not
carrying an old uh some no you talked to
him this morning and
then you just realize everyone's caring
like moods don't it's like uh
you can't it's like i say it's like
eating in a greasy diner you
you can't get out of your clothes right
i literally can't like ugh
i was thinking of remember back in the
day people did smell-o-vision
stuff it's the problem is you can't get
the old smell out to get a new smell
yes so all the [ __ ] smells are in
there yes
and it feels like there's just there's
no smell
the mood comes and it goes and it
doesn't stay it's a process you can
literally metabolize feelings
in a faster and
with wisdom and not
i don't i find myself again it's been
two weeks but
less quick to like cortisol
less quick to stress less quick i just
yeah but like you said you use your
wisdom because sometimes people
who have bad anxiety or depression it's
like i'm a blank year old
i'm a 35 year old blank or something
yeah and like and i'm still stressing
out about this stupidest [ __ ] where
now you get to use your wisdom behind it
it's really good it's fine it'll
probably be i know what's
he's gonna have to go through like i
didn't even i'm still
being a bad text group texter with
trayvon and royce i'm like guys i don't
like this
like i don't like like they were sending
me all the nate robinson and i was like
i don't
care i just just don't look no i know
but i was
i again they were like joking like
guys you know me but it is still
i just don't i don't i don't like
violence no but i don't
i just don't have time for dumb [ __ ]
well and a testament to ayahuasca is
that me and you are
very different in terms of our mental
health and our
orientation in life and it's we still
both found
yes we're both at different came at it
from different
levels of expertise i'm expert i'm an
extrovert
and you're already i'm in office at uh
feelings
um i did a double yesterday on uh
hulu i went totally under control the
trump
uh i can't watch this so
i want to i want to watch them so bad
but
it's just it's a lot it's a lot it's
more about
there's less bombshells it's like it is
like more of a
tick tock but it's it's it's
when he knew and what they did
and you can't you still kind of there's
as much as this is a slog it is hard to
remember everything
yeah um so it was helpful for that and
then there was a banger
of a documentary called kingdom of
silence that's the one on show time
about jamal jamal khashoggi
and uh a banger good yes because
saudi and and um
that region that region in that tax
bracket
is very easy on the ice meaning
all the everything that takes place it's
like was
in riyadh at the four seasons like it's
just not
it's like it's all palaces and pulling
up at a thing in it
so it's that plus intrigue
and there's way more to jamal khashoggi
that i didn't know
like he was like kind of
the closest journalist to to uh
bin laden which i didn't know which
again none of here's what i came away
with
which is wrong of me especially in light
of what a [ __ ] i am
um
um on the um
one of my caffeines this show's about to
get way better um
on the in terms of
them ordering a killing
right yeah
it seemed a little bit in-house
the problem is meaning they had beef
with him
he was cool he was kind of a mouthpiece
for the
for the regime right they were the
kingdom didn't they warn him a little
bit
a bunch before it happened he was a
mouthpiece for
one of the princes like truly and then
after the arab spring there's a lot of
good arab spring stuff that i kind of
didn't put together
that that saudi was sort of
instrumental in putting down the
insurrection in egypt
and so there's stuff where
to quote executive producer chris rock
i'm not saying they should have
did it but i understand like it's just
some mob [ __ ]
yeah but you're not allowed you're not
allowed to act like
what's funny is you can't kill a guy
in a in a
count on a consulate but with a drone on
a field
[ __ ] have at it yeah then it's like
yeah how many how many wants
how many people you want to kill 100
yeah that's about right um
so there's like there's just a lot of
it'll make you think a lot but it's also
more there's more to it than i that i
didn't even
put together yeah and wait i did a dock
i don't know how new it is it was called
far from the tree
did you see that uh i said it came up
what is it
it's um this guy wrote a book and he
interviewed he wanted to just see how
much
we actually get from our parents in
terms of
everything physically personality-wise
blah blah
so he wrote a book and he researched it
and he
just interviewed people from
a lot of different backgrounds with a
lot of different
disabilities just jobs all over the
place and then it's
so it's like it's actually interesting
it's an interesting documentary to see
these people and
what they got from their parents
sometimes they inherited something
physically wrong
or personality wise or blah blah and it
talks about
it just examines how much
of an influence our parents have on who
we become
and is it by nature nurture do they do
they figure it out
no they so that's the thing it's a good
documentary
in terms of being interesting because
they interview so many people from
different backgrounds but
they don't conclude anything and it's
the same guy who wrote the
book that i guess was a best-selling
book uh far from
fall far from the tree um so they just
kind of
interview people that all their stories
are so interesting
so it's a good like time passer but
you don't get a definitive well yeah
because
of course i mean there's no yeah it's
interesting i would say
okay the background yeah just the best i
like that idea and i like
thinking about like what did i what did
i get and what
it's like um somebody whose parent
someone
like there was a kid who
uh one day
stayed home from school waited for
he was a teenager waited for an
eight-year-old to walk by and slit his
throat
and they interview their family and
you know what they can't like
just the things like did we contribute
to this you know what
that kind of thing they interview
someone who with them physical
disability
i realized i watched this doc crazy but
not insane
about kind of the leading woman in the
late 80s
on uh multiple personalities
disorders and it's on hbo
and it's it's not good
she's kind of a weirdo
she's like a new york weirdo and
uh like i can't explain it any other way
like the kind of lady who we used to be
on donahue
all the time oh still donna here like a
little flamboyant yes like a little
flamboyant but the clinical
they're a clinical psychiatrist and
you're like why are you doing so much
press
um so that was it but she worked with
with a lot she worked with
um ted bundy she worked with some of the
greats
uh so it's not it's it's as well-made as
it could be
but she's so flawed
it made me just realize that i don't
like when people do
multiple when they have multiple
personality disorders because they
not trained actors it's so bad and it's
so
embarrassing have you been like i'm
mikey oh
god [ __ ] i hate this the one on
like in the i loved talk shows when i
would come home from school and watch i
i watched every talk show and when they
would have someone with multiple
multiple personalities on first of all
think about that
very not cool to have someone who's
under like a
mental health breakdown yeah it's like
who are we talking to now one would
yeah she's here and you're like oh [ __ ]
i hate
that i hate that i have to watch this
yeah one would have glasses
one didn't need glasses yeah apparently
they found out
multiple personalities not a thing i
know well that's they didn't cover that
in the documentary but
but i feel like it is she's she's pretty
convincing
i mean you i mean this is spirit padre
but i
it's pretty convincing that someone
could be
they're the acting's bad but
there is some credibility to it the
stuff that they confess to they're like
but yeah it makes me so uncomfortable
they're like yeah josh
my name's josh i'm tough did you watch
split
the movie the show that
was he was basically just doing mike
myers characters
in split like he was just doing like
fat bastard he was doing i i when i
haven't seen a while but i was like oh
that's mike myers uh
he was just doing differently i'm lucy
it was
so [ __ ] embarrassing it was it made
me
so uncomfortable and it was a horrible
movie
but he was awful that's what i found
he was so bad at that thing because
did you see
please stop talking just talk like
anybody
do do the art of
speculating voice yes like
do please do anything but this
i'd rather hear that i'd rather hear
that because at least i know what he's
doing is bad at it where it's not
right and it's oh and i don't i can turn
it off whereas with it
multiple personality so so
[ __ ] cringe as the kids say it's so
crunch
um i had a useless observation
this is actually kind of a heartbreaking
observation no
that i don't believe that
human beings will ever conquer
time travel do you know why i say that
because no one has come back through
time
that no he's got a little something for
you
listen there are people who have claimed
to be
show me a car i need a [ __ ] ship
show me a flux capacity show me
something you gotta expand your mind man
they can't bring
objects
so come here and explain the technology
you used
yeah i think they do and they're just
like when everyone's like
okay when was this there's a few
yeah i'm gonna send you but you're gonna
need their jackie robinson they need
their lady kicker
uh ladyfoot to come and yo i'm about to
send you so
many of them and i because i've seen no
one's come back and say
hey i'm from the year blank and here's
some [ __ ] from that year
and good news is we conquer time travel
i'm a normal person
it's just going to be a while okay
there's some there's some there's
something
[ __ ] but you're trying some alien [ __ ]
you don't want to hear about you're
trying to justify
no there's something special like they
can't bring [ __ ] no because they're not
saying
something and then what happened you're
i'm
you i pity you i'm telling you i pity
you that okay well
i was in the article but some [ __ ] has
been predicted
that we didn't know in terrestrial
science that they found out later like
what
like there's certain moons on certain
planets oh boy the north node
no it's just that we're back on just
like yeah
uh uh what's is that keith uh what's his
name send a
keith song song oh a keith song he sent
it
when he sent us on for when keith barks
which he has known in a while
i know where is he
making big barks with your mouth keep
making a big monkey
monkey pretty good he doesn't he doesn't
bark that's right
where has he been he's downstairs our
own relationship's never been are you
sure
positive he keeps himself he didn't say
hi to me you come up
well that's on you no no he always says
it maybe he's not in here
no no okay oh you saw him
keith [ __ ] i mean pretty big deal
let's do some emails
st
you've got mail that's nice hey
neil and beyonce i would love to hear
your take on
that was eric johnson that song about
keith
hey neil and bianca i would love to hear
your take on something me and my female
friends always argue about i'm a guy
i think the main reason for a lack of
women in certain jobs construction
mining driving trucks etc
is not sexism but a lack of demand from
women for those jobs my female friends
say that that is not the case
in a perfect world every job would have
50 50 gender ratio
what do you think greetings from
istanbul
a heavily muslim country
um town on the hill uh
we need a song for that um sneezed
um i don't think that women
want to do certain [ __ ] and i think that
they don't i don't think that
this is one of those things where women
will go like no we want those jobs i had
to argue with my
jamilah about how all all of her friends
would date short guys i was just like
i don't know what to tell you you can
keep saying it
but there's no i know for a fact that
women don't like short guys
generally doesn't mean they won't date
them again you're looking for a caveat
in general they're not going to be
attracted to short guys
just in general and they're not going to
want to dig holes
they're not going to want to they're
just not going to want to
the problem is not that us as a
collective need to agree that we all
want to do construction
[ __ ] no most women will never go into
it's a problem is that why why do you
think that is though
um i think it's hard i think it's
grueling by
i know a lot of men being a mom is the
hardest job on earth
no i'm just saying like women say that
trolling women
no i'm just saying it's it's just
because you play you play it both ways
where it's like
no that's too hard and then it's like no
but being a woman and a mom
and a stop i'm being so when people are
up front
then you troll then when people don't
admit you're like you would never be
so here's the deal no one wants to do
construction let's be honest
a lot of construction workers don't want
to do construction it's not
a fun looking job and a lot of guys
don't want to do that [ __ ] right but
would they but they do it for the money
right do it to like because a lot of
people don't have options a lot of you
have records a lot of people it's just
really easy whatever it's not so much
that
i don't know this 50 50 generation of
[ __ ] no
uh it's that when a woman does want to
do that
when she's the outlier and she's like i
want to do that heavily more like male
dominated thing
they get stonewalled they're they face
tons of sexism and
it's that's not that's not cool i don't
think that yeah that i can't speak to i
assume it's true no but that's it that
is what do you mean that i can't speak
to you can't
divorce i don't know what kind of
stonewalling women
face in construction i mean anything you
know it's there's a reason why
some things are there's reasons where
it's just i think human nature
why things are heavily male yeah
dominated and female dominated
and it's that that i don't think that's
the big debate it's that
why is it when a girl wants to do that
guys feel uncomfortable or they feel
like they can't
i think it's some [ __ ] [ __ ] in that it
might be some [ __ ]
it's they just want it how it's been but
you know it's funny
remember a classic one of the greats
uh cool runnings you know how they tried
to
enter the bobsled world and everyone was
not having it
yeah apparently that was completely
[ __ ] fake
and when they did join the bobsled team
all the other european um teams in that
olympics were
so excited that black people were
bobsledding
i'm sure that they were so nice super
supportive
helped them out when they needed things
yeah and that was the real story the
real story is that everyone was so
[ __ ] nice to the jamaican bobsled
team but that
wasn't a good story well they wanted
weed
you know bianca did they cover that do
they do they cover the wheat
the wheat the white people casually ask
them if they have
so like are you guys um no make it
european make it [ __ ] the art of story
of spaghetti
i'm from belgium
anyway so i don't know why people aren't
like that like
welcoming they're like they just let a
lady kick her
kick i don't [ __ ] i like i don't
think that it is so
obviously people are so disappointingly
stereotypical that it's shocking
right but i i don't know
i don't know if there's if women on like
film crews or commercial crews whatever
face a ton of sexism that's
like look at the game like open
hostility probably not on film but you
know i don't know i don't know what it's
like in the crew but maybe at first they
did and
that's right is there a time is there a
situation where
when a woman came around not that you
were dating
you were less you're having less fun
you were less comfortable like
that's like a writing thing sometimes
meaning like if it's you and two other
dudes and you're just
the way you guys well the time it's like
she can hang
kind of thing yeah and what it means
probably i think what we probably mean
is like
she'll be sexist sometimes or she'll
she'll
co-sign or at least not tell on us right
uh which isn't to say like me and jost
are going like
and these women but there's i don't
i've never written with a woman and
thought it was
less fun because there was a woman there
but i am of course an angel so but
there are i'm sure there are people that
probably
sure like you know that they've seen
rooms used to be all white dudes so
i'm sure when they first came in sure
there are 55 year old white dudes coming
like
here comes another woman of color yeah
and [ __ ] i'm in trouble i'm the worst
um totally yeah but i feel like you've
heard that [ __ ] no
yeah like i don't know if though
that guys like that just sound dumb
that's the so when i hear
of course there's still sexism but if it
if it's like the jobs are
truck driving or mining i mean truck
driving seems like
there's a an assault issue when
women don't want to drive alone by
themselves
uh mining i mean
women love women love diamonds
somebody who did a joke somebody joked a
woman did a joke about gold digging she
was like i would never dig
um construction
i don't know it seems like i don't know
if it's like
that you're they would get sorer than
men i don't
under like anatomically if a woman
couldn't lift all the same [ __ ] i would
not feel safe in a car i
ate lunch one time waiting for an
audition outside
of a construction zone for an apartment
three dudes knocked on my car window i
was
eating a sandwich minding my own house
shut up cut to me i'm gonna deep throat
deep roading a foot long
i was just like leave me alone yeah so
yeah
they're idiots yes there are yes then
there's also the part of it that is so
not evolved no it would be it would
shock me
it would it's the 70 trump voters like
or 70
70 million trump voters i'm like what
but i'm also not surprised um goodbye
anyhow you've got mail hey neil and
bianca r-e-s-t-l-e
um i was listening to neil talk about uh
musicians who get signed for two million
dollars
uh advance on their first record and
then you never hear of them because it
doesn't do that well
i gotta say i think you're talking about
some like pre-napster
like pre-this century stuff i don't
think that happens anymore
at all i'm an old man and
i don't think it's ever going to happen
again
what's more there's like no middle class
in music anymore like yeah there's like
mega mega mega mega stars
but most of you know i've been doing
this 20 years i was up for two grammys
this year
and you know covet notwithstanding like
it's hard to make anything resembling an
adult living
you know i think the bet i think the
10th best jazz musician in the world
probably is making
what nate bergetsi made 10 years ago no
disrespect to mate
you all just have stronger unions and
better contracts
and netflix is doing what spotify
isn't and i mean you know it is what it
is i don't begrudge anybody anything but
just so it's clear musicians are not
making any money and the
and the model is not allowing us to um
thanks for making such a great show
yay uh i don't think that i was saying
that musicians were making a lot of
money i was really only talking about
the taylor swift's which
i spoke to somebody about all that stuff
and somebody knows what he's talking
about and he was like
you just don't sign your publishing away
you just that's the rule it's like it's
stranger danger
but most people do of course they do
because they want
the money it's just that they want the
money
they want the short-term money so they
just sign
and and also like for instance
take snl for for example
lorne and i think he owns
everything now at this point just
because it's he's been able to
renegotiate renegotiate
um now when the show sucked in the 90s
they were taking [ __ ] away from him
literally negotiate undercutting him now
that it's been been on a good run he
owned
he owned all the best of will ferrell
dvds and the best of
steve martin and dan akron and belushi
and he owned all that [ __ ]
and will didn't make
very much money on it but guess what
lorne didn't get a piece of elf lauren
didn't get a piece of old school learned
like it's the exchanges
i i get underpaid
and i use it as a launching point yeah
like the the thing i always say eddie
murphy made
105 grand for 48 hours
yeah that's insane so
then he made 30 million for shrek 3 or
whatever like you just get the
if you stick around long enough you're
gonna get the money um
so what with that guy what what that
guy's saying is yeah i don't musicians
are not
there's also so much music now and
everyone can make it on their computer
so
uh i don't think that there's a crazy
good living to be made i just think
in people do take advances that's what
i'm talking about i'm talking about
people
complaining about i'm talking about
taylor swift basically
complaining about it don't there's a way
to avoid it which is
your dad is not a [ __ ]
her dad [ __ ] sold five out you know
what i mean like
the the and the the it's the thing i
said which is
if we end up being you too right
it's a bad deal for us meaning they took
a bunch of money up front and
if they'd sold a bunch of records
a conglomerate would have owned it but
they just
kind of were like right
let's see what happens it's a fickle
it's fickle i'm actually surprised they
give you the option
they don't well here's the other they
don't really give you the option they
they give you the option
that was a renegotiation but they don't
give taylor swift the option
because they don't they don't give a 15
year old girl an option they go do you
want to be
you want to get shot out of a giant
cannon that we've built
right like that's the lorne thing but
then it's when they're saying don't
sell your pup it's not like if we did a
movie it's all like we can say
give us less for point i know that is
sort of yeah like i don't make
nobody i mean we me and dave made dick
on half baked
yeah like dick coolio did a song and
made more than us
not even kidding no the song apparently
the guy
who did the theme song to mash made more
than anybody
associated that's the music because
publishing again
it's weird steps on i was like do you
want to just make the themes
yeah any well that was a that was like a
famous song but yeah
it was yeah suicide is painless no i
know what it is but did he
redo it no it was a it existed i believe
it was already a song
and they just licensed it oh it was
already a song and that guy was probably
making diddly squat on it
yeah or he was already run out of money
or whatever they it's just a simple
thing
of lauren for instance shoots
unknown people yeah people that he sees
in a theater with whether the attendance
is nine people
right and then he goes kristen wiig is
[ __ ] great
or will any one of them and then
will and then lauren goes i got a cannon
in new york you want to get shot out of
it
and they go sure yeah of course i want
to get shot out of the cannon
so it's like they just and they go and
he goes all right well it's a long
contract
etc etc etc i own it it said okay
it's a fair deal unless you become
one of the biggest stars ever yeah and
even again i don't think will would
will for instance i don't know who's any
one of those best death dvds
like seth jim seth meyers jimmy
they all lauren owned their dvd
too and then now they're
they can negotiate against nbc because
they're popular because of lauren you
know what i mean like
yeah it all kind of works itself out it
doesn't work it's about
uh for the best but it does in some ways
like
there is a bit of an ecosystem
so and that's why
half-baked is the greatest goodbye
you've got mail
dear neil and jar jar banks i'm a i have
a
whole novel typed out full of my dumb
[ __ ] feelings and mental gymnastics
but last i got the long ass letter song
played on my ass
let me give you the bullet points uh
we'll get the song ready
pretty long dude six years ago this is
actually an interesting thing okay
the noble a lot of these people write
garbage this is interesting
six years ago when we were 23 my best
friend was killed in a work accident
uh probably construction that's another
reason why women don't want to work
there
it was the hardest thing i ever dealt
with in my life including the death of
my father when i was in high school
um your father who who your friend
murdered
um i am now and have been in love with
his girlfriend
since his death oh no obviously his
death was as painful and difficult for
her as well
we leaned on each other every day
heavily during the grieving process and
our friendship grew
that much stronger two years later i
ended up telling her how i felt about
her
she rejected me and told me she doesn't
see a future in which we are together
out of respect for her and myself i've
never brought up my feelings again
knowing that i wanted to remain friends
with her no matter what else
uh and not let things ever get weird
nothing sexual has ever happened between
us beyond
hand-holding and cuddling uh i've tried
to date other women and be happy for her
as she she's had sometimes serious new
relationships
six goddamn years later and i'm typing a
letter to you
to say that my feelings for have never
faded for a moment she's the only person
i ever imagined wanting to have a
serious romantic relationship with
even if we tried and it didn't work out
at least i would know for sure and don't
doubt for a second that we will remain
in each other's lives
as friends uh i don't see myself
bringing it up to her again
and i have no idea if she knows i still
have these feelings for her she swears
she didn't have a clue the first time
i felt like if i never bring it up she's
never going to pursue the matter
in my experience women don't pursue men
um
it's too much work it's a hard job
that women don't want to do come on guys
construction construction
seems like i need to just suck it up and
live my life but i don't want to spend
the next five decades pining after
somebody
who doesn't want me um what do you two
think
any experience with unrequited love
specifically one tied up to the most
emotional scarred tissue
uh in the most emotional scar tissue you
carry around with you
how what are we feeling thinking thanks
god bless
look if you went through that and she
still didn't like you
she's never gonna like you the
cuddling's a little weird
the cuddling is shitty on her part well
maybe
maybe it was when she was crying yes so
we don't know
yes uh meanwhile cut to like what he
considers cuddling it's just them
driving
like she's in the seat they're there
i would say pull away
from the friendship because
it's never it's just a it's
it's gonna it's just a tumor it's you're
feeding it
you're giving it a blood source you have
to pull away from
the relationship and you will see really
how
important this is to her i mean this is
for her if she really is feeling
something
but she can't admit it and you're always
there and you
she probably [ __ ] knows you would
lick her [ __ ] in a heartbeat if she
called you
um guys give off that energy sometimes
no neil oh my god that was so small
padre breathe on me breathe them right
now exhale exhale
exhale um so
she probably knows it i i would pull
away a little bit because i don't think
this
this isn't a full friendship for him
this is a
this is like uh wait yeah it's you know
it's your stand down and stand by
you got you're you're you got you got
ulterior motives
100 so i do think you should try to pull
away a little bit
because it'll be better for you don't
keep feeding this this is gonna
you're not and also you're always gonna
compare someone
and if you date someone and that girl
needs you
and i'm your girlfriend and you're like
i gotta go it's a problem
you have to nip this in the butt so if
she doesn't come after you if you pull
away a little bit
she's never this is never going to
happen i've got to say another point for
ayahuasca
if there's not enough that i
uh i was invol whatever i there was a
woman and
there was a woman okay her name was
mother ayahuasca uh no there was a woman
and
she kind of like stopped
[ __ ] with me right and i was really
curious as to
why and then since ayahuasca i've been
like doesn't matter
doesn't matter why no it just matters
that that's
what she thought what if what if every
advice we give to our letters is
because he imagine if they dated two
months
she's obnoxious or something
then it's then it's gone it's an artist
it's controversial telling yourself this
story like
it's right because a mikey it's just
like bad cinematic
it's cheap cinematic i mean like we
gotta do this and always about the
narrative with you
the other the other issue is
um that
it's a small market issue yeah where the
[ __ ] is he from meaning
no there's no [ __ ] way this is in a
city snowy town
it's the it's the small market like you
don't have access to any women he's not
la new york or miami and he's not in
miami
he's not in atlanta no he's not in
dallas not in houston no february
he's not in chicago he's not there's
just not a lot of circulation of women
so
a woman like that becomes
everything and you you and we i helped
her with the thing and
did it and then you got it yeah and then
you realize like oh she's just a lady
here's the thing and it's insulting to
both men and women so
hear me out fine uh it's
you know factory settings it's it's like
when people
in out in la will be like i think i
might sign with a new agent it's like
dude
i would say it's like women they're all
kind of the same
men are all kind of the same there are
you can customize it
get some spinners are to speculate and
you get spinners you can get a fur wheel
you can get a [ __ ]
big hydraulics but it's still a guy
or it's still a woman like no one's
that atypical gender-wise
um i mean in a few years once but people
are fluent of course and we'll talk to
that on we'll talk about that on my
other podcast
um called don't listen to this um but
so yeah it's you you've pedestalized
this woman
and pedestalized and you don't
yeah yeah like you did you don't got to
do this
and you don't got and by the way
yourself no one
she wants you to tell her you're feeling
for her about as badly as i want
a multiple like i'm jeffy that it's the
[ __ ]
oh
nobody wants to hear your feelings yeah
even if
because she's happy with where it is
she's having rose
she it sounds like you kind of work for
her even though i don't
even feel like he doesn't feel like he
do a lot of chores
if she needs you know right away and not
to be a [ __ ] but
they were 23 and she was his girlfriend
they don't have kids
like who knows how long that
relationship with us that is rude to say
about the deceased i'm just saying you
know
it was his girlfriend yeah i don't think
he's got a problem that it's morally
wrong or anything no no i'm saying
um when someone's husband dies you feel
really like
if they have a kid and you knew the
husband you feel very
you know i gotta help the family yeah
but this is like young love she's going
to find a replay
you know she's had multiple i worked at
the [ __ ] ice cream shop together
you're 29 and if you live in a small
town just move out
and experience the you don't cheat this
woman may be great
but uh it's not gonna happen
it would happen by now she would have
said she would have just made
it's like you know how you can you can
tell when a woman
likes you it's because she'll make eye
contact with you for more than two
seconds
like women are very to themselves if
they like you they
the whole game right energetically but
if they don't they got a lot of time
for you and a lot of like let's stay and
do what they want to do [ __ ] with you
it's not where this just sounds like
how'd you fix the light goodbye goodbye
there's there's some one meme
of a girl walking almost like a caveman
and it's like
how women walk by a group of
construction workers
they're just like don't no no please
don't look at my business
nothing i don't know turn it off
um you've got mayonnaise in the banks
rst
in response to a letter neil commented
that there's something romantic about a
red flag
and this is the pitfall many women fall
into while red flags can sometimes be
signs of a major danger
down the road they can also be signals
that simply disqualify you as a match
and they are often seen early romance
movies and literature often show these
challenges fixable
it is part of the true love never did
run smooth trope
women aren't just addicted to the
happily ever after women are addicted to
that sad heart-sinking feeling when
something goes wrong
when he leaves or argues or doesn't want
what she wants
it's part of the appeal unfortunately
for women that red flag is part of the
fantasy
it's the challenge the obstacle that
must be overcome
uh whether it's his immaturity or uh
mental health concerns women take on
that responsibility
this isn't she doesn't have a question
this is just like a public service
announcement
uh but it's true and it's
i was thinking there should be it would
be a sketch it would be like
game wipeout oh yeah i think they used
to
work for it did you do the track before
they would do it
um that game wipeout but just
relationship problems
that women want to [ __ ] duck like
fear of intimacy and [ __ ]
oh man all that [ __ ] that women think is
part of the so much so much wasted
energy it's so it's just it's also so
insulting to the gut like
i've been i have a joke that i haven't
done yet but it's
women think they can turn mules
into thoroughbreds and it's like he's a
[ __ ] mule
he's going to be miserable and you're
going to be miserable it's not
seabiscuit
it's a [ __ ] i'm telling you that's
right
okay but my argument here is that
sometimes
as someone who's been in a situation
like this a few times
the guy really
really is great up front and then you
[ __ ] hang out too long and you love
them
and then they really do a dump and it's
not
me going after someone who needs my
[ __ ] help god
i mean kill me but it's like
i never might last you i just it's a lot
of dumping
and then girls are very you know like
nurturing so it's like okay
i was talking to somebody a woman today
um and
she was saying that she's getting more
picky about who she wants to date the
older she gets
and she said she's had guys
she's had guys she's like i there have
been guys that i wouldn't sleep with
until like i was their girlfriend
and then we slept together and they
changed
their mind while i was while we were
in postcoital like lying in bed together
so which makes me think like do women
need to spot
men sex meaning i don't
that sounds weird i'm not saying no no
but what i'm saying is
you you know that a guy is behaving a
certain way
for sex yeah so it's almost like
look man here's sex i'll have it with
you and then what are you actually like
who who are you actually because he
changed his mind
he changed his mind because he [ __ ]
got what he wanted
right but which is sex right but that's
a [ __ ] that's a weird that's a
[ __ ]
well that's what i was saying that's you
should be able to call the cops
as a woman you should be able to call
the cops it's like not rape
but it's like what is that that's like
it's you should be able to call the
better business bureau
because it is that it's like i got
ripped off yeah
i got i said it should you be able to
call like the [ __ ]
you got dick ripped and you should be
able to call like the channel
seven news teams on your side yes call
like something needs to happen
yeah this is wrong it's true because i
think if
you are clearly communicating most guys
if you say i'm looking for something
serious and
they'll be honest because they don't
want any problem they don't want
miscommunication
like i'm not looking for anything
serious
yes and then the funny thing is though
there has been times where
i've gone on dates with guys they keep
wanting to go on date they have already
mentioned they're not looking for
anything serious
i say hey i'd love i i had fun hanging
out with you but
you i think maybe we're just i'm more
open to something happening
and you like express your boundaries so
you know
maybe it's not a good idea we go out
again they always want to go out again
yeah i mean that's the that's just
because they want to yes it's
because even though i know if we just
[ __ ] they'd probably be like
okay no i don't lie yeah it's like
they're just so you're right yeah
that's the better it's like you don't
have to you just have to sense
whether what their intentions are in
that case they said it
i took them at their word yeah and
they're like well you know well that's
i think a lot of times it's like men say
i'm not looking for anything serious and
women say
i'm not looking for a one-night stand
and we both go we'll see
right we'll just we'll see and then
that's funny
all right everyone's will sing i love a
good boundary tell me yeah
bye goodbye um
so the woman's right and they're not red
flags are not romantic this is a really
good
email though you didn't even read all
this no i don't know so naturally there
was a red flag in real life women stick
with it because they think they will be
rewarded
if they can if they can just push
through this sad feeling and then fix
them
they will get what they want in the end
their way it models truly unhealthy
behavior on the part of women and the
men
it shows women that if men don't
disagree with what you want
they need to change instead of
considering the possibility that you are
simply not
a good together yeah that's the thing
that i
i was talking to a woman and i was like
i said women a lot of times
get upset that they don't get a job that
they didn't want
anyway it's like i we're not a good
couple
right you you've been on our dates
but then you know i feel like i've
fallen into this
some people really it's a grammy snub in
a way it's a grammy sniff
it's a but some people bomb
at the beginning some people get a
little too anxious
and they get excited and dudes bomb and
it's like yeah
i've had to tell guys what happened but
yeah go ahead
i've had to tell a guy you're gonna
scare me are you crying
no just cleaning my glasses oh i seem to
wet
keep talking
you're gonna scare me away you gotta
chill
i like you do they do they get the hint
i do
i think it's an anxious attachment sort
of type thing
but uh i try to give people the benefit
of the doubt even if i see a red flag
because sometimes everyone's just
it open miking at the beginning and it's
like yeah i
i get just bombing i think it's a weird
it's how they bomb yeah i mean
so i can forgive some of them i went on
a date with this guy
and he i was like oh you have friends
from college
yep they're my roommates and i'm still
friends with them oh cute
what what's cute about that he said this
yeah and i was like oh well
i don't know it's cute he's like hmm
okay i was like well
what what's wrong he's like it's a
little condescending i'm like how's that
condescending he's like
well you don't you don't know enough
information for it to be cute and i said
well cute doesn't have a high bar
were you in 9 11 cause that's the only
way it's
like not cute then it's meaningful
that's the only way it was so awful
i was i could not believe and it got so
much worse which i won't explain
on the but he was yeah well there's [ __ ]
like that it's like
i've never can't overlook that i got i
caddied for a professional golfer when i
was in high school
and the guy said a thing that was
like maybe the best advice i've ever
heard
about life okay he said he's a
professional golfer his name is nick
price he was like
kind of famous in the 90s he said i
don't need to know where my good
shots are going to go i need to know
where my bad shots are going to go
meaning as
people we know that
it's the kinds of mistakes you make are
the [ __ ] where your life gets [ __ ]
up like
am i do i just like cocaine a little too
much like
putting yourself in positions that
are uh just thought out or knowing
where you might [ __ ] up in relationship
i bomb early so you know if you bomb on
dates
you have to you have to like prep
yourself right know
where you're [ __ ] and if you're
bombing
it say it yeah get in front of it yes
like know where your bad shots are gonna
go yeah like
i somehow drive drunk so i you know
whatever you're
whatever you're [ __ ] i vomit i bomb
it i
i used to be really obnoxious me like i
used to be very like
yappy this is like when i was like 19
2012 on dates
all the time what do you mean i was just
like obnoxious
like talking like constantly talking or
talking
yeah constantly talking and thinking i
was funny
and i probably was a little bit but like
chris hardwick
thinks i'm obnoxious from
singled out in 1995. still
like i know he told me how did you
curve that behavior clinical
oh depression no i mean i think i just
realized
did somebody say somebody did you say
something yeah well what they used to
say
is you seem like more of a performer
which is what they say to writers that
are annoying
um uh
yeah like it's kind of dawned on me
like you gotta slow down a little bit
like when you first get roommates and
you start realizing the best oh yeah
yes like oh that's where my bad shots
go okay all right we might have the bark
sign coming up
that's right you are alive keith
oh he's upstairs he was killed oh that's
why i was like you didn't greet me
oh he thinks the dog walks
with you she might be
wrecking ourselves
damn how the [ __ ] could he hear her they
have incredibly good i mean that's like
their thing
dog unless they get it he's adorable
unless they get
covered you've got man bianca this is
more question for bianca i'm sure neil
will have a perspective to share
because he is annoying and chris
hardwick said so would love to hear both
your takes on it to give you some
background i'm half persian
dad moved here in 78 got himself a white
girl and here i am up until i was
up until i was going to school i grew up
very immersed in persian culture spent a
lot of time with my dad's family
and spoke decent farsi i was raised very
secular arguably anti-religious in
hindsight
uh god was occasionally mentioned but
that's about it
all the persons i know generally have no
problem sharing their racist view on
arabs
and for what i can tell it mostly comes
from the fact that they strongly dislike
islam
get in line uh line starts behind me guy
uh especially these french for i mean to
be 5.6
uh they feel that islamic theocracy has
ruined their homeland and that arabs
which they
credit for inventing and spreading the
religion are to blame another major
point of criticism is that arabs who
move to the us tend to continue
practicing islam
far more often than iranians their
viewpoint being i came here to get away
from that [ __ ]
why are you holding on to it you're
doing it wrong you idiot
um other liberal persians i know are
equally weirded out by the left's
fascination with being so warm towards
islam
i think the intention is good but
misplaced islam
for all intents and purposes seems to
simply be an offshoot of christianity
both monotheistic
both monotheistic have a good bad
afterlife commandments jesus muhammad et
cetera
if the evangelicals decided to start
making their women wear burqas liberals
would just consider that a new thing
that sucks about them but if it's brown
people with a slightly different
religion
now we all need to be tolerant of their
[ __ ] i get that a lot of muslims are
not fundamentalists
but a large majority are correct me if
i'm wrong
when it comes to gay rights women's
rights and other social issues i
imagine that traditional islamic beliefs
fall far more into the
republican camp and that seems to be
ignored also just to be clear i don't
think christianity is superior they are
all equally not true
as far as i'm concerned last lastly
binky your impersonation of iranian
speaking english is dead on and i love
it cheers
is there a question there was no
question there okay
well that but he basically enumerated my
like my issues
the association i just made is the way
republicans feel about
trump is the way
liberals feel about islam meaning
like but you're against all this right
but
not when you're against it i'm not
meaning after 9 11
hey no one gave a [ __ ] about islam
before 9 11. it
barely came up no like it barely ever
was mentioned
like ever even in the
in the middle east crisis in the 90s it
wasn't about islam
it was about iraq what's his face
um and uh so
this that's the problem is that it's all
and it's the that's the civilization
stuff i'm saying where it's all
anti-women anti-gay
anti it and it's very anti
and to a white ear it
seems more sour than christianity
because i know
the difference between christians and
it's that joke i did about it it's like
christians are horrible at being
christian muslims are still
kind of good at it right there hasn't
been a reformation where you throw out
most of it
like there wasn't christianity so that's
what i think french people are saying in
some ways that's what i'm saying
but because after 9 11 liberals felt
bad for uh the racism
that muslims were accepting were on the
receiving end of
so they felt protective and okay
and so now but if you really think about
it it's like what
what about this do you like liberals but
then again
week that same argument could be made
for like
liberals and black people i mean black
books are pretty
there are some uh
lgbtq issues black people
and that ends up you know even if you're
not super religious
if you if you're black and you have
black family you have i have uncle i
have a mom
so you know i feel like everyone has
problematic views in their
community not liberals
not at all so i think it goes everywhere
not just islam i
agree but
islam is a
that's all it is blackness is a bunch of
[ __ ]
he's loves a lot more than that what do
you mean meaning
it's a religion blackness is a race and
it's
a bunch of different religions a bunch
of different ideologies 100
i'm just saying that within islam there
are
you know it's not just islam you know
there's it's
culturally also islam is different in
different countries that practice
i mean former yugoslavian so your
serbians montenegro and stuff they drink
they drink and they well they just
ignore
a huge part of islam other places you
know it's it's like anything so
yeah i don't get why it's so they're
because they haven't had a reformation
that's the big thing it's like you you
know about
uh montenegro drinking because it's
it's an aberration from most of islam
whereas no [ __ ]
western country follows any christian
rules other than
don't kill and abortion sometimes
um and that's why
that's what muslim islam looks like
to westerners and if you know about it
which this guy does
you kind of know the downsides of it
and you're a bit like it's it's the
clash of civilizations thing where like
this is not gonna go well like
when these two things come up against
each other
it is but i do think that there there's
a lot more similarities
just conservativism and stuff like that
that's
everywhere but we don't talk about like
we don't talk about
i guess it's not flashy enough to talk
about how
a lot of white people are pretty [ __ ]
conservative even just dressing
and you know a lot of them were like
if they made the woman wear burkas
liberals would be outraged
that's his point is there stuff that is
accepted dogma
even in fairly secular muslim countries
that if if republicans did it
liberals would be up in arms because it
would be like this is anti-woman and
anti-gay
but because of 9 11 they feel a special
need to protect it which
i i as an old person i can tell you did
not exist before 9 11. what i'm saying
is that
i think if you can pick any
we're kind of framing it as liberals to
muslims
are kind of hypocritical because a lot
of islam is
anti-what liberals stand for but yeah
you could do that with a lot of other
minorities and what and then which i
would follow that up with
is and but we know that they don't
actually follow it
so that's the thing that's comforting no
but there's a big that's
what wars are started over that [ __ ]
like that's what
that is but a lot of people here are
just like practice
islam and do assimilate with society and
still there
yes and i think they they're
sort of off to the side and that's fine
and they're in manageable numbers
everyone's a hippie
you're born michigan they are in your
room and
uh and it's fine but once you get into
big numbers
and as a
all the things you are i think you
feel an inclination to be like that's
just islam baby
no like when i was in iran for example i
did understand that
it did make me think and i would not
want to live in iran
because you don't have any social
freedom which is generally how you get
away with
other of prohibiting other types of
freedom is giving people social freedom
yeah so it's like
you feel free but you're not [ __ ]
free right whereas in iran it's really
which they'd say in the name of islam
what it's a theocracy that's why you
can't drink you can't do much
exactly right instead of a constitution
that you're like the quran but
in iran it's as soon as you step outside
you're
you know you feel the boundaries of your
freedoms
immediately especially as a woman i
believe it and so
when i was there though although i i
don't like it
as you know a western girl i did
i did try to understand where they're
coming from and
maybe though our relationship with sex
in western cultures is a little
problematic
i don't know if it is i like how it is
right
but i do think there's something if you
are more conservative about sex
i don't know how obviously it's it's so
much money is for
female genital mutilation more than i am
i think that they have a
great idea i think it's a some of their
sex ideas are really great
that's what i'm saying like there a lot
of muslim countries are
for that and liberals just ignore it and
this guy's going like
this [ __ ] is medieval the difference and
i think your
what you're doing now is
uh you feel white it's like white
heat it's like french heat and white
heat and you're like no
come here islam you do have some good
ideas about no no
i'm i don't think that and also
uh iran isn't a super it it has to be
pro-islam
and before like the shock it's like
during the shah they were not allowed to
veil at all it was the opposite right
so it's so i'm just saying but the
reason why
iran is in this position is because of
like a far-right regime that took over
and killed the opposition so i a lot of
iranians here do not like islam because
just like
cubans don't like right so it's the same
it's just bad ptsd
so i wasn't raised in a pro-muslim
household at all
but i do think the french
really love to ignore how we got to this
problem
and we're just like islam is just being
so problematic and it's like
yo there's a [ __ ] there's a reason
why yeah they did it
to themselves of course they did but
it's really hard for me to get behind
it's like no
but i'm not but i'm not talking about
i'm talking about
i'm irrespective of country
and irrespective of regime
i'm talking about liberals this guy in
particular is talking about liberals
signing with islam i know it's a
hypocrisy but it's a hypocrite
my point is it's hypocritical everywhere
find me a situation where
one side isn't making an exception for
when it helps
their bottom line that's what i'm saying
yeah and i don't know but i
but this is this guy speaks very well
goodbye he speaks the white he's well
speaking he's pete i mean this guy's a
[ __ ] i must have read the
speculation this is uh the finally
you've got me this is an email that we
got i am writing to disclose to you that
you were
affirmed as the beneficiary of the asset
and wealth
of the late craig feel
is this real yes no it's not this is
spam because they think my they just
google spam
they think my name is neil phil and my
uncle craig
no please respond when at your earliest
means to obtain more information on how
to claim your benefits
and then there's an address also there's
it's
it's period no space best regards yes um
the late uncle craig this is a shock you
hear about
but this is the first time you've seen
three mics that have actually been a
beneficiary
of a dying person so it's very exciting
and bianca we're going to be rich so we
officially
don't have to take this [ __ ]
craig feel is the new thank you uncle
greg he's the new ep
craig fields craigslist
goodbye
um
tell me